what's up Victor Cruz Lozano how are you
doing don't fantastic we're doing it you
guys here in football players you guys
do a lot of charity stuff all we care
about with this charity is our place and
other shows we're being bit higher than
which is probably the wrong no I know
they're all coming off like the chance
to sit in the studio with some of the
show's got soo and like we want to make
sure that we're like beating Andy Cohen
and we are eating Andy Cohen beating
Jenny McCarthy like we just want to make
sure I don't care how much goes to the
charity but as long as we're number one
win yeah this is all about and then we
look better then we're gonna use it as a
negotiation tactic for the company right
now we're not doing that we're not doing
poorly but we're not doing amazingly
wouldn't want to do better yeah we'd
like to do a little better so we've
tweeted out the link in everything I
guess it goes to charity but i mainly
retweet us yeah we'll see what happens
thank you hey guys out there yes Victor
Cruz the the face of Gillette right now
right yes Gillette clinical clear gel
now is it a pain in the ass though to
know that like you're going to go around
today tell the world about Gillette not
that that's a pain in the ass but
knowing like yesterday you're interested
right let rules I use gillette but
you're in Pittsburgh yesterday okay and
you're like I gotta finish this game go
through all of this and then get myself
to New York so I can go on this press
run and like take myself away from from
that mentality yeah I was a difficult
not really it is it just the only
difficult thing for me was waking up
this morning to be here yeah wake up and
start the day you know we got back a
little late last night got back around
midnight 1am something like that and
then to go to sleep and wake up and have
to do this that was the hardest part but
other than that once you get going get
rolling it's always fun Gillette
clinical clear gel is it's fantastic I
put it on this morning so if you smell
good i got i want to say that when he
walked in be okay smell around the toi
here bunch of men just complimenting
each other i smell fantastic it's fine
you just i would say you smell like a
really quite delightful do football
players just get used to having that
like singular focus because i'm sitting
there like yesterday as I'm watching you
play I'm in my head going like well this
is what I'm going to do tomorrow and the
next day the next day but like you can't
do that like
you have to sit there me like this is
what I'm focused on this today I'm
focused on gillette tomorrow I'm going
to be focused on that is that we is that
a discipline you have to learn
absolutely i mean as an asset you have
to learn how to compartmentalize certain
things when you're in that moment you
have to focus on that moment not think
of anything else even prior to the
moment when you're preparing like
pregame and you're preparing for the
moment you have to place yourself in
that moment and not think about anything
else and I think as athletes that's one
of the biggest keys one of the biggest
attributes that you can have is being
able to lock in and focus on that moment
then when that moments over we move on
to the next so what do you do when you
start to loose like when you start not
wandering because I wander all the time
it's really hard to stay focused there's
gotta be a time we are gonna huddle
you're like what the [ __ ] did he just
say oh yeah well I think you like it but
you're in the field you're waiting for
something and then you're just thinking
about like I was watching on TV are not
out a time based on lines before like
what am I supposed to say there's like
this is you ever run a pattern you like
I don't know if this it's coming to me
or not the beauty of football is that is
a team sport so the minute you know
something goes wrong you not you know
you owe you forget something i can just
look over at Odell or sterling be like
hey what was the play oh you know you
have other people to lean on sansome so
footballs a little bit different but
there's definitely times where you space
out but you just kind of realign your
focus get back in the moment and be good
to go were you annoyed yesterday you're
not you're not pleased um I won't say
annoyed not pleased is obviously a
better a better term and you know
anytime you go through a game where you
plan and work your butt off all week
long to prepare then you go into the
game and you know you don't catch a ball
you don't get a target naturally as if
you're not upset something's wrong nice
you you're playing the wrong sport
you're doing something wrong so just as
a competitor I just want to be able to
go out there help my team win and
perform and play and unfortunately
didn't get a chance to do that
individually last night what happens
during the games your point where you're
like okay is it gonna come to me or is
it not like I don't know how do you do
you ask would you say to the guy like
you're gonna throw it to you ask eli
manning ah no not necessarily obviously
you understand the schemes and
everything that we're trying to do as an
offense and and getting things going on
the right foot but as the game goes on
and you know goes later and later into
the game you kind of see how it's
shaping out you can kind of see that you
know if it isn't this series it isn't
going to be the next series that I'm
going to get a catch and you know all
those things so um you know it sucks and
it's not
is not the greatest feeling the next day
it's somewhat embarrassing even and and
you just want to try your hardest to you
know do better than that the next week
is there an instinct there's got to be
and this isn't any anytime you're doing
any type of sport where something
happens and somebody screws up with a
past drop turrets overthrowing you like
I was like I was open yeah like why did
you make that mr. why didn't you come
here i was why do you allowed to say
that in front the other team team
members are no i think there's a way to
say i mean obviously you can go and be
described to be like man i was open on
that and make a scene or have you seen
guys do that of course I mean you see
that all over you know the league from
time to time when guys don't get the
ball or whatever the case may be but the
right way to do is to go to Eli like hey
man you know I was open on that last one
just you know take a peek my way next
time we call that call you actually do
that that like I mean we've all seen
like adele is notorious for throwing
tantrums like on the sideline is very
and then it's like you take this breath
and you get it out of you but I feel
like when you're in the midst of
everything it's going to be very
difficult to not be going over and and
shouting your head off it is it is but
you have to understand that you know
yelling and screaming isn't gonna solve
anything in that specific moment you
have to calm down realign your focus go
to your quarterback see what he sees
because he may there's a different
trajectory he's with that perception
that he's looking at and what you're
looking at so you want to just go up to
him and say hey what are you seeing on
this play that I didn't get the ball and
I was open what what are you looking at
and then he'll you know assess it and
he'll talk to you and then on the next
play when he finds you on that plane
hits you with the football to the film
so how do you feel you guys are playing
dallas this week i mean i'm a big cowboy
friend i bleed cowboy green I don't
think that's different yeah I stopped
watching you watch Jim likes Jim likes
to watch the cowboys when they're doing
very very well it's kind of hard not to
want a credit for it yeah I mean once
they were one and one I said this is
gonna be the year it's kind of feeling
that there was a big win streak coming
up you knew it yeah yeah sense it but
you guys do what you guys waiting for
waiting for now yes so do you feel like
s you feel covered do you have a play to
you can't say you don't feel confident
but like let's say over the past years
do you play somebody and go like we're
gonna get our asses kicked this week
there's gotta be a time of you know way
no we're now never go in every game
under
anything that you got a shot to win if
you do all the things right if you
execute properly you can beat any team
on any given day that's the beauty of
the NFL the parody you know in most
years is pretty crazy it can be very
very tight tight you know close-knit and
teams are very much in the middle of the
pack and so you get one of those years
like the Cowboys at 11 in one and things
like that I panic is a fan that when i
see that i don't want 11 in one because
that means they do right there dude
almost like what was it when the Vikings
was it was it more than adding the
kicker at that time when they were he
was like he had not missed field goal
all season and you like that's a
terrible terrible streak to be on if i
miss once it's going to be when they
needed to go to the playoffs of course
of course I how do you and I would
imagine that that feeling of like
anything can happen probably only gets
better when like you go into a Super
Bowl is the underdog and you walk out
it's like yeah this proves it that
there's you can't go into a game and
think you're gonna lose but how do you
you talk about like individual
accomplishments and then being on a team
how do you keep your ego in check
because at times like especially when
the media just decides you're the guy
like after that Super Bowl it was all
about you you know I mean when you do it
was Victor Cruz when you talked about
the Giants it was you it was the dance
it was the whole deal like how do you
stop yourself from going back next
season and like being like okay guys
stars here exactly we can do this I
think a lot of it has to do with two
things one on my teammates teammates
they don't care about any of that stuff
when you're in that locker room you're
another team million you're a guy that
you know they're gonna jet joke and
laugh and poke fun and you know so my
teammates keep me humble and keep me
honest and then my family my you know my
support system our mom doesn't give a
rats you know what about super bowls or
catching footballs or any of that she
wants me to take the garbage out if I go
by her house she wants me to you know
clean up after myself properly when I
get over this so she's the one and my
family and my circle are the ones that
keep me level-headed and keep me you
know they don't care about the
touchdowns obviously they're cheering
and they're happy right and they don't
mind seeing you out exactly on whatever
it is Regis and Kelly I guess how bad is
it trying to what's the word that I many
tickets to family
the family asked for tickets to take us
the worst is that awful then why did you
tell because there's so many there's so
many people that want I mean operating
at a deficit because i'm from this area
from born and raised in paterson new
jersey oh yeah so all your all your
friends you haven't spoken to her coming
out of the woodwork can imagine there's
so many cousins that I never met that
are called me for this cowboy game oh
yeah oh yeah that I'm just like who's
your uncle oh no no I'm not sure I
remember him like who is it was he at
the Reunion I don't know we do you get a
certain number tickets and that's it oh
well no you can get as many as you want
I mean that they're gonna take it out
your channel you're taking orders I'm
gonna get three free and then after that
you have to pay for them so I think it
can get quite pricy but you know that
all those cousins that you've never
heard of are all telling all their
friends how close they are with
absolutely all of oh yeah it wasn't
diapers together when you started making
money for the first time is that
something that you had to deal with
immediately like realizing that this is
something that's gonna follow me as I
continue to make money and I need to
figure this out absolutely i mean the
biggest thing for me i mean i'm the
nicest John universe with my friends
with my family I'm giving I want to do
the most I want to help you in every way
possible but the biggest thing I had to
learn was to say no I mean yeah there's
certain things that you're just not
going to keep paying for and keep
shelling money out to regard family or
not because it's just not it's not okay
it's not right right at some point you
have to work for yourself and do things
yourself and I will help you and it
doesn't always have to be monetary you
know it can always be with my presence
or with a connection or resource or
whatever the case may be so that was the
biggest thing I had to learn was just
how to say no I playing football
everybody knows your salary yeah it's a
public thing it's not like you can line
and go ahead are is they think that you
know someone signs for 20 million
guaranteed they think you got a check
for 20 million right and it's in the
bank right there to check it in and they
want a million of it like you can spare
a million you're fine yeah so like I'm
waiting for it that's not biggest
misconceptions like how do you also do
talking about I guess I don't know if
it's an ego question or what it is but
when the when the media decides that
they have like a shiny new toy right and
and all the headlines start going like
Odell's way and everybody's talking
about this guy
I where everybody used to be talking
about you it doesn't change what's going
on on the field it's just this is the
guy that they're all talking about does
that do anything to your self-confidence
is it kind of like you know who's this
guy or are you good blocking it out I
mean it's not even about blocking it out
I think I mean let's be honest I'm a guy
from Paterson New Jersey and undrafted
free agent seventh year in the league
Super Bowl champion like I'm I've
already accomplished so much in a placed
in a space that I'm not even supposed to
be here if you look at it you know
statistically even the way I was brought
up in my road to success not supposed to
be here so regardless of who's getting
the accolades or who's getting the you
know the front page of the newspaper
who's being talked about I've already
accomplished so much I'm not worried
about that I'm just worried about
fulfilling continuing to fulfill my
legacy and whatever that entails and
continue to live life the right way and
and you go from there and obviously it
does I mean he's like a brother to me no
you know none of that stuff can never
affect me or you know rub me the wrong
way well tell you this Gillette clinical
clear gel or know if you guys have heard
about this deodorant it helps you stay
three times dryer and fresher it's it's
the real deal and I'm not being polite
when I say smells really good he does
right its key I'm creepy gentleman yeah
it's very good luck I hope you have a
great game this week and and just lose
by close right I hope it's close I hope
you guys do well but lose close cousin
Cara against Dallas